but not having it now I have our sister
from care can you introduce yourself
my name is Mara I run the Kerry San
Francisco Bay Area office and I'm a
civil rights lawyer now I'm gonna ask
the first question is that okay with you
guys all right you're all on the deep
stuff many Muslims are flying nowadays
we got to get here we got to get there
and have faced much discriminate some
have faced there's a lot of good people
sometimes we highlight a lot of the bat
but there is much more good overcoming
the bet I think so what do you think yes
I think that there are so many more
people who are saying we want to scan
with the Muslim community especially
close Trump like there is hope and I
know we're not alone Tom didn't die now
you've had people also on the other side
they spoke in Arabic and they said god
is great all praise to God said on the
label degree in Jesus and they got
kicked off plank recently I think we can
derive some benefit from this story if
there was a brother went viral all over
and he was saying he was speaking to his
mom and they kicked them off and etc etc
so the two points to this question one
is and then there's debate about was it
a praying was at this that and that goes
back to what I was saying earlier
following the Prophet SAW some people
were choked and we're honest notes okay
all my friends know now the important
thing is what do you do you're the
attorney if you come across and what
constitutes race is up or Islamophobia
and you're in this predicament right
you're an older lady
man young man young woman and give us
some live example of really there's no
debate about it where someone actually
went through something of this and how
to handle them good question so in the
past year we've received at least a
dozen complaints from across the country
people have been kicked off the planes
some legitimate some questions it's
always hard to say so here's my
recommendation to people who might be
traveling get to the airport on time be
polite and be courteous know that
everything that you put in your bags and
your electronics can be searched and
then also the reality is that airline
staff have a lot of discretion they can
kick people off of planes they can't do
it for racial or religious reasons but
what gets challenging is proving that
right so if I'm yelling on the plane in
English and Arabic and Spanish and or do
they can kick me off but if they only
kick off people yelling in Arabic then
that's going to be discriminatory the
hard part is proving it so what I tell
people is look dot your i's cross your
T's be a well-behaved passenger and then
if something happens call care don't
make it worse don't get into a physical
altercation you don't have to answer any
questions from law enforcement and
generally airlines have been good about
putting people on the next flight
because they want to protect themselves
from a lawsuit now that doesn't mean
that there isn't legal recourse there is
but that's where you call care don't
start a fight get off the plane be
polite call care if you can here's the
thing that technology and cell phones
matter record the interaction don't be
confrontational in doing this and this
is by the way something that
so if I'm getting kicked off and brother
Eddie's like what what's happening to
sister's Accra he can pull out his
cellphone and start recording and that's
really helpful later what I'm saying hey
it was because I'm Muslim and Delta
Airlines is like no no it's because you
were this well brother Eddie has the
video that says who was right and who
was wrong and provides more context and
it's a little bit more neutral of a
video if it's not my video because I'm
gonna cut a video and edit a video to
protect myself
Delta's going to do the same thing and
so brother Eddie's video is going to be
really helpful come did it laughs let me
get one more can I get one more yeah
maybe you guys it's good that's your
mission you're not little enough it's
good okay now you're on social media
right and you you see there's a lot of
people out there
they've been affected by the
Islamophobia machine quarter-million
dollars annually spent throwing dirt on
Islam submission with God and now if you
see something out there and you get all
emotional and a lot of the things you
ignore because okay there's a lot of
trolls but how would you respond have
you ever watched Miller fortune yes love
connection also yeah do you know have
you heard of now it's one thing when you
just a layman is saying certain things
but how do you take it how would you
respond let's say to a famous individual
one in particular it really saddened me
hopefully this can reach our brother
humanity and others who just kind of fit
it and me to start throwing dirt also so
the tweet one of those something like
this can I just say that 10 years ago at
conferences like this we did
about Twitter because it wasn't even a
real thing which is just interesting
about how time is move amazing so now
you're on Twitter and now you experience
the Islamophobia Chuck Woolery you maybe
grew up maybe some of you guys here
you're a little bit young but your
parents are like that or you see someone
else you identified with someone else
from a reality show something else that
maybe you wasted your time at one time
and now you see this person saying
something similar to what this man said
he said if you don't know Islam is evil
am i miss quote now know if you don't
know Islam is evil then you don't know
history and you refuse to reason I'm not
saying that every Muslim is evil
different now Muslims like hold on Islam
is evil on practicing Islam I must be
evil maybe I'll go to some evil no no no
how would you respond to Chuck if you
saw and empower the youth here not to
get shaken by things like this can I
take one step back and say something
about social media that I always want to
make sure young people understand and
elders understand to everything you put
on the Internet is permanent so if I
here's what I say if it leaves your lips
or fingertips it is forever Allah sees
it the NSA reads it it ends up in an FBI
file and it could end up on the front
the New York Times now that's true
whether we're talking about extramarital
affairs like the former senator from New
York or we're talking about how we feel
about Isis and al-qaeda right is that
when you delete it from the internet it
doesn't go away forever and that's
really important to remember when I see
horrible Islamophobia or when I see
injustice is across the world that I
want to type something ridiculous right
once it's there it's forever even so the
companies take it the FBI can see it and
we know that they look at our files my
haters are going to screenshot it so if
I'm like oh my god I hate brother Eddie
that show is so horrible I can't believe
I belong panel with him
someone's gonna take a screenshot of
that and it's forever twitter has it
right to look important to remember once
it leaves your lips or fingertips Allah
sees it and everyone else does too
there is no take-backs think about that
before you hit Send or before you hit
post so what do I do with Chuck and
others who are talking anti-muslim trash
on the internet I would screenshot it
right because you want to make sure now
this is true sometimes if it's an
elected official you want to go after
them you're going to need the screenshot
because they're going to take it down
and it's easier for you to access that I
want to think about who their friends
are so one of the things to be strategic
about is I don't know Chuck why is Chuck
going to listen to me maybe he will
right but maybe he's gonna listen to
other people the other thing that we say
to people is like to be be thoughtful
about your approach so look Donald Trump
might be beyond reason for me like I'm
not sure that I could have a nice
conversation with Donald Trump of course
if Omar were the alarm on who converted
to Islam on his way to kill the prophets
anything is possible I'm just not sure
I'm the person to have a courteous
conversation with Donald Trump or Chuck
or others leave Donald to me yes okay
good so Eddie's got Donald I'm not even
sure that I could do it with Chuck I'm
not sure that I have that kind of
patience but there are some people who
have tried that right so the two things
that I would suggest one see who their
friends and influencers are maybe there
is someone that's going to be more
sympathetic that they will listen to
that you can get to first right in that
same way like look I want mom to get me
to give me permission for something
maybe I'm gonna ask my favorite her
favorite kid not like it's not that the
assets gonna come for me now that mom
has favorite kids and then the other
thing is think about engaging in patient
conversation if I collect talking on
linear races to reward a bowl of deer
are you that might turn him off that's
not to say that some people don't
deserve that they absolutely do but in
some cases the first way to try is
patient conversation what would you give
me give me a minute
a personal Chuck you know it's such a
small world
chuckle Wolverine he checks the tweet
Chuck we got love for you that's what we
sent his message give a person on one
thing what would you say that person
when you hear somebody student maybe who
knows Islamic mean sincerely look into
it just and it tasted penetrates the
heart that's why is the fastest one way
of life out there that provides peace
and purpose and
tell me dr. Joe Chuck because he might
he might never he might never make that
human connection I'd love to talk to
Donald Trump they might never be a
Muslim so you mean I'm Chuck Chuck I
love ice cream and coffee if you are
down to talk I think Eddie and I would
be willing to have ice cream and coffee
with you and just talk to you about
Islam and Muslims answer any questions
that might that you might have or
clarify any misunderstandings that you
might have what's to say ice cream is on
us oh I'll sit but I don't in the sugar
I'll take it well then you're not
invited I'll do the juice how about
juicy we can do some vegetable juice
people are less nice over juice we need
you okay your guys turn go ahead